good morning believe nation today's
message is create holistic success over
you lisa nichols success is personally
defined by everyone and as you're
creating success create holistic success
I'm I bit my biggest successes are the
things that people don't even see it's
the fact that my 14 year old son caused
me his best friend to his friends that's
bigger that's bigger than any book deal
that you can give me that's bigger than
sitting across from larry king or beside
oprah that my 14 year old son calls me
his best friend creating holistic
success is really important so the
question that a today is I'm curious
what the success mean to you for me it's
about having impact I make these videos
because I want to impact a lot of
entrepreneurs I want to reach a billion
entrepreneurs and have an impact in my
personal life you know I I sit on the
couch and watch Game of Thrones with
Nina and I want to have an impact on her
I want our time together to be
meaningful I take the family to Disney
World because I want Hayden to have
memorable meaningful impactful
experiences I'm I feel successful when I
feel like I'm having an impact on other
people's lives I'm curious what success
looks like for you leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event specimen
okay
espresso give me go